No, no, Adri, es eso, eso da igual,
déjalo, déjalo que si no no has echo la
bronca. O sea, aquí hay aquí hay
personas que están contratadas para
descargar todas las máquinas y ponerlas
en su sitio. Que hecho, yo antes por
costumbre descargaba todas las máquinas
y se me acerca, me dice, "Tío, por
favor, deja las peces ahí que si no me
echen el trabajo, porque básicamente
estaba quitando el trabajo."
Hay gente que su su trabajo es quitar
las hay gente aquí contratada en este
gimnasio que llega, pone todas las peas
en su sitio, todos los discos en su
sitio y no quiere tocarlo. De hecho, se
enfadan si tú lo haces por tu cuenta
porque básicamente le estás quitando el
trabajo.
Así que lo dejamos así. Eso lo
descargamos después. Ah.